the taliban is back in the news
because that would be quite an extreme
of authoritarianism the taliban are back
in the news because as they have now
taken power in afghanistan
some news crews are getting interviews
with them and one news crew is making
fun of a
taliban official because they handed him
a globe and they said where is
afghanistan and this dummy
can't point to afghanistan on a map
he's holding up the globe they're
speaking some barbaric language
i think it's known as french
and he's looking all around he just
can't
taliban official there is uh you know
he's struggling
and then the guy walks in and says there
it is there's afghanistan
what a dumb idiot haha that stupid
taliban guy he doesn't even know where
it is man he's so dumb
so
the taliban official
can't identify the country on the map
you know what he can do though
conquer the country and uh send the most
powerful nation on earth packing within
like 11 days
that's what he can do so hahaha he can
he he doesn't know how to use naps
hahaha what oh but you know what he can
do conquer the nation that we spent 20
years trying to conquer
he he might not have a whole lot of
technical knowledge he might not have a
whole lot of book learning but he's got
a lot of practical knowledge
he knows how to
control afghanistan
he knows how to do that better than
the americans
better than the soviets better than the
british
better than a whole lot of really high
falutin fancy educated people there is a
difference between technical and
practical knowledge all right
book learning and how to really do stuff
and
the ruling class of the united states is
really obsessed with technical knowledge
and it's why now we are sending kids to
school for
many more years than we used to and
we're obsessed with
funding pre-k and funding college and
funding post-graduate work and funding
all sorts of things
and yet people seem to be getting dumber
right our ruling class which has so many
degrees they're so credentialed
they can't keep the supply chain running
they can't keep our money
valuable
they can't keep
the country running all that well
but they've got degrees pete butterjudge
has a very impressive degrees he doesn't
know anything but he's real he's got
really really impressive credentials and
i think part of the cause of this is our
hubris
and specifically it's the hubris i don't
want on both sides of this it's the
hubris of the ruling class where they
say haha those deplorable irredeemable
rubes those bitter clinging guns and
bible-toting idiots ha ha they didn't
even go to princeton
yeah i bet they can do more things than
you can okay they might not know a lot
about foucault or gender theory or
something but i bet they know more about
things that actually matter and then
things that frankly are actually
true i'm so glad you enjoyed that clip i
enjoyed it too you know i just felt it
sounded good it looked good i'm glad
that we can agree on that if you want to
see more clips if you want to see the
whole show subscribe here ring the bell
also head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play for free
you can subscribe to the michael knowles
show podcast helps us get around the
sensors that come up every now and again
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you